alright guys the perfect date it's just
the perfect little movie isn't that it
was so much fun I want to know what you
guys think makes it the perfect kind of
rom-com and this rom-com revival we're
in to me it was a little bit to all the
boys that live before
alright I gotta say have you heard of it
did you guys check that out no no when
we were filming this it hadn't come out
yet after I was like had you talked to
them at all about making that movie when
you guys are filming this one you guys
should be so we had like talked about
what we done red blushing right but you
probably didn't know how big it was
gonna be no March so I just filmed it
like five months earlier four months
earlier yeah and by the way okay so I
legitimately knew nothing when you first
mention it never told you this and you
weren't actually talking about like this
at all
I'm not sure why I thought this I
thought it was like a thriller I I've no
idea why I thought what do you guys were
talking about it like it was like kills
all like slowly I'm like oh this is so
different than I'm in a sequel if you
want to pin totally just it was so good
though so I was really excited because
obviously the producers of the perfect
date it was called the Santa Ana the
perfect date you know ditch all the boys
and so I will say after I saw all the
boys I was a little worried that the
perfect day was a little similar so I
haven't seen it yet and then after I saw
it I was like oh no it's like there's
some pretty woman in this I mean you're
a male date the perfect date like tongue
I don't know do you see it on a gigolo
you want it specify not on that level
have you and Lana talked at all about
having this experience where you're both
in a fake relationship with the no
synteny
so I haven't met Lana and I'm like dying
to meet her so not only we can bond over
that but I'm also like semi kind of
obsessed with her I think she's like so
cool yes um but I think it is hilarious
that he knows in two different movies
that he's in a fake relationship with
them and not only that but I also felt
like the Sierra Burgess it was kind of a
similar like mmm you're applying to call
it I just have commitment issues
never you're actually be in a
relationship to your question man the
perfect date I feel like compasses like
a lot of different qualities outside of
just the romantic side of a rom-com I
mean this is witty you know you see a
friendship being challenged you see you
know a young woman discovering herself
and accepting yourself and you see a
young man going through the same thing
and it begins with the question Who am I
you know and and I think that's a
question that so many kids our age and
every agent adults is just trying to
figure out so there's a lot to this film
outside the rom-com aspect I mean yellow
I mean do you feel a little bit
responsible maybe a little pressure for
the revival of the rom-com you've been
quite oh no oh not really man I feel
like I just got extraordinarily lucky
and I just want to keep working well you
guys I'm gonna could tell before we
started here you guys all seemed super
closer with each other
how much fun did you have making this
movie and what you kind of do when you
got a chance oh man we shot in New
Orleans and you know that place is
famously haunted so we were even you
know we were we were checking out some
haunted houses you know around town it
was fun are you guys believers it was
more like complicate we really were
wanted to prank the production off yeah
no one cared we like put a ladder on a
table and like no one ever did
stepladder kitchen they didn't notice no
ones that we thought it was pretty cool
but whatever I think we all very
instantly kind of connected which was
awesome like right away we would I don't
know why the Noah's room just became the
room to hang yeah probably just wanted
to kick us out all the time we would
just talk for hours and hours and it was
a really great way of like connecting
off-screen that helped us on-screen when
we had to shoot the scenes we were
reverse
yes Annamarie is called the perfect date
and in it your character will wear a
costume we'll do whatever to create the
perfect date for someone what is maybe
the wildest thing you guys have done to
create the perfect date or maybe that
someone else is done great I have a
really really cute one I feel like it
back to the were storyteller
I knew that we weren't gonna be going he
wanted to surprise me and I knew that we
weren't gonna be going to the place that
he named some I love ruining surprises
it's one of my favorite things in the
world I think that makes me sound
terrible but I'm just like ah you
thought you got me but you didn't what
are you totally got me so I knew we
weren't going to this restaurant but we
just went to this um park that was like
a really kind of special place for us
and he had lit up the entire park with
trees it was pretty and he was playing
Jamie Mitchell and we had this sugar
fish to go you knowing this now have you
done anything on this level either view
for days no what's the craziest thing
you did maybe you've got a trainer me I
mean I guess you know I feel like I mean
outside of taking vacations like I'll
take you back to your hometown
ok so you're planning a vacay oh hell
yeah I like that I like planning like
like a week that's kind of like this
whole thing ya know I've never done that
that's a lot it's also in the movie in
the movie you guys your characters come
up with this app and it's just such an
interesting you know way to meet
somebody
is anybody dating on the app so you guys
into the app no no no no I've never I've
never okay I'm lying I'm physically
lying I tried when I was younger my
friend was like oh I think so try it out
I was like no I stopped very quickly
after I don't know if you guys ever got
deep into this never Freedia I used to
be in
do it for sure like I used to like
beyond bumble I was on this app called
Riya when I was young right for sure
bumble but it's for people that that
shares certain networks and peripheral
networks okay the most perfect way to
describe it without being yeah no no I
gotta ask you guys though like look
after to all the boys live before coming
out obviously things blew up for this
guy when people find out you're in a
movie with him there's anybody like hey
can you introduce me like have you
gotten that pressure not yet okay not
yet I wouldn't be surprised man I
wouldn't be surprised
I've known Noah for a really long time
and so I know a few people like my
family loved him and they've loved him
before like obviously told the boys came
out so I remember when it came out we
were all just like he's so good we're so
it was like we were so exciting New
Orleans we were all hanging out with
your hand with his mom my favorite part
is that like he's just completely the
same guy like just even when he was 15
did you ever see yourself
give me a member Calvin Klein ads come
out oh yes oh your reactions great but
let me ask you doing movies like to all
the boys in the perfect date now with
these great people were you ever seeing
yourself in this like rom-com heartthrob
role did you ever think oh one day I'm
gonna like kill it in all these rom-coms
oh you know I never really like put them
put any sort of indicator of like what
genre I wanted to go into but like
honestly it's like the like career as
far as like been an indicator of where I
was going yeah hundred percent like I
was your love interest on Austin and
Ally and many other Disney or
Nickelodeon show or any like thing I
booked outside of this one pilot was
always love interest boy-next-door
romantic interest whatever it's not
completely like far-fetched that it
would happen but I was never
I feel like we were all convinced you're
Mark Ruffalo I'll take that you and Mark
talked about this I mean you're like you
can play his son no problem I would love
to yeah I would love to mark markers
like a huge inspiration versatility last
question for you I just got asked any
sequel teased news you can give it to us
I want to show the entire franchise I'm
here to break my heart
it wouldn't please I know I'm not sure
how much like you say I mean no it's
just like I was not expecting this like
reflection I'm going to I'm going to
Vancouver very soon huh are you excited
about the way it's shaping up and
looking yeah we met with with director
and producers and Lana and I speak
pretty much not all the time but we've
been speaking a lot more lately as we're
getting closer and we're all very
excited she's chemistry reading new
actors for the for the characters and
competition will we cry in the sequel
probably nah
I hope so if you didn't check out the
perfect day guys honestly there's so
much fun it's like every that was big
you hang out there it's like if and I
just want to like grab my girlfriends
and wine and watch it's such a fun oh
[Music]
[Applause]